time being 9:30 we will open up long
range Capital planning and utilization
committee uh welcome all here
today um we will uh start with uh the
acceptance of the minutes motion for
September 15 Mr chairman I I move we
accept the minutes the September 15 2023
meeting thank you move by clud or
seconded by Mills if you're in favor of
that is there any discussion on the
minutes omissions
Corrections
hearing none if you're in favor of that
motion would you please signify by
saying I I those oppos nay uh the
minutes are carried
unanimously uh I would like to move on
to uh new business disposal of highway
or Turnpike funded real
estate and um we have items
036 disposal of 0.11 acre of land and in
Dorian Road Town of
Windham item
037 authorization to sell a parcel of
state-owned land located on the easterly
side of New Hampshire Route 31 in the
town of
Greenville third item I apologize third
item Department of Transportation
requests authorization to sell Point 09
of an acre State on land controlled
access right of way located eastly side
of Route 103 town of
Newberry and our fourth item by uh
highway is request to approve disposal
of four contiguous Parcels of vacant
land state-owned land located US Route 4
Dober Road in the town of
Chichester um and with that would you
please
present thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Steve leonti
I'm the administrator of the Bureau of
RightWay with the New Hampshire
Department of
Transportation um the chairman has
already provided you with the pertinent
facts I will simply add that with item
uh 36 in Windom the department plans to
list it at
$40,000 item 39 in Greenville the
department plans to list it for 13 well
not list it sell it directly for
$113,000 item uh well item that was item
37 item 39 Newbury uh the department
will sell it directly to the abutter for
$14,000 and the department will the part
the
item uh 41 in Chester which is made up
of four different partials the uh the
department is going to list that with
nii Norwood group and that will be
listed for
$229,450 th000 all will be assessed an
additional uh $1,100 administrative fee
I can answer any more specific details
represent Mills yes sir is that uh
$229,000 or just 29,000 okay yeah for
the record thank you Senor thank you
thank you Mr in the first one you said
40 but it says wood 40 oh I'm sorry I
meant to say 140 it it for the question
please follow up okay that that that's
valuable property down there one in
Windom yes it's part of a larger well
right yes and no it's part of a larger
uh mitigation area that two of Butters
are already interested in it um what one
of the abuts approached us about buying
it we went through Surplus review our
Bureau of environment said it is Surplus
to our
mitigation just because we paid dearly
for that we lost
lawsuit for that property I'm talking
about the big picture of it we lost a
significant lawsuit right we did lose a
pretty big lawsuit down there yes
thank you thank you Mr thank you Senator
further
questions seeing none um we have a
motion on um um should we do individual
yeah I think we should um
036 motion to approve sir I'll second
motion made by Mills seconded by
cier um any further
discussion if you're in favor of the
disposal of item in
036 signified by saying I I any opposed
motion carries item
037 authorization sell parcel easterly
side New Hampshire Route 31 town of
green
Bill motion to approve sir motion by
Mill seconded by cluder further
discussion you're in favor of the motion
for 037 disposal signified by saying I I
any opposed motion
carries item 39 request to sell 9 Acres
state owned land controlled access uh
easterly side 103 town of Newberry zero
motion uh Senator delandro moves the
item seconded by Mills
Mills further
discussion if you're in favor of that
sale of 0.009
Acres um town of Newberry signified by
saying I I any
opposed
none last item for this this is a 041
request disposed of four contiguous
Parcels uh route four do Road Town of
Chichester to approve thank you Mills um
makes the motion I'll second second and
by cluder any further
discussion item number 041 if you're in
favor uh signify by saying I I any
opposed carries
unanimous
yes uh thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to comment that I really
appreciate the detailed packages we get
on each of these so that we can actually
look at them and detail ahead make sure
we don't have any questions thank you
thank you point well well
taken um Department of
Safety be item uh 040
23040 uh request authorization to lease
approximately 076 Acres of state owned
land at 17 Dock Road always a lot of
action there Guilford New Hampshire
please
will ad
to operated by the department of safety
Marine Patrol at 17 Dock Road this
10-year lease will provide um beachcliff
Executive Center U the use of the UN
currently unused land um for Consumer
parking for the restaurant located
adjacent to this property um any
improvements will be made at the cost of
the lety and subject to all permits from
the Department New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services town of
Guilford and approved by the department
of safety um on October 12th 23 the New
Hampshire Council of resources and
development um recommended to approve
this lease as well we're looking to wave
the
$1,100 administrative fee just due to
the small size scope and the nature of
this
lease thank you are there questions to
Department of
Safety seeing no questions um pleasure
the
committee on thank you Senator delandro
moves uh
040 Department of
Safety 076 Acres state owned property 17
doc Road any further discussion I'll
second it second Thank You seconded by
Mills I thank you for that any further
discussion
seeing none if you are in favor of uh
item 040 Department of Safety signified
by saying I I any opposed seeing none
motion carries unanimous thank
you would like to move on to
item uh 038 Department of
Transportation uh request authorization
to sell a approximately
12,800 Square ft
029 Acres parcel measuring 400 F feet by
30 feet on state owned CH uh Chester
Branch Railroad town of Troy uh for an
amount of
3,120 with that Luke please introduce
yourself good morning chairman members
of the committee my name's Lou Barker
I'm from the Bureau of rail and Transit
the Department of Transportation I
oversee property management of
state-owned railroad
property presenting
an proposed sale of a sliver of the old
chesher railroad Branch adjacent to the
Troy Depot where the town has a brought
in a rail car a historic rail car to
display and
uh since the property
is ancillary to the Integrity of the
corridor we agreed that we would proceed
with the sale
um we had an appraiser look at the value
of property in ch in on the chesher
branch and in the town of Troy and we
came up with a
uh cost and breakdown that resulted in a
suggestion of
$3,120 plus the administrative fee
that's what we're presenting to the Comm
the town of chest uh um excuse me Troy
has uh would like to be recognized
because they would like to make a uh
request for a modification to the uh
price U further questions or um allowing
the uh allow the town to talk um for the
town of Troy would you just come forward
with uh with Mr Barker and
please okay with the rest of committee
we'd be happy to hear what you
request please introduce yourself good
morning um chairman Mr chairman and the
members of the board um my name is Kim
chaffy I'm actually the his um I'm the
chairperson for the Troy historical and
the chesher railroad Depot I manage um
both of those buildings um in the town
of Troy and as Mr Barker had said we
just received our Bud our DC 6154 to put
with our 176 year old fully restored
Depot should I go okay all right um okay
I did um I did write a a letter to Mr
Barker um asking on behalf of the uh the
Troy historical society and the chesher
railroad Depot um we would like to thank
you know him and the state of New
Hampshire for working with the town of
Troy first of all we actually have a
temporary use agreement so we were able
to um reach that agreement and put our
our Bud car on it with the understanding
that we would move forward with the
purchase of the land itself um and you
know they so you guys they helped us um
reach that and we were able to place our
Bud rdc1 uh number 6154 she's was built
in
1957 um and she actually ran the chesher
line for a very short period of time so
that has historical feature is is next
to our Depot now so it's kind of like
she's back home um we would respectfully
like to ask the state of New Hampshire
to sell this piece of property to the
town of Troy for $1 um and you find
basically a rationale and and the reason
for that is the town of Troy purchased
the Cheshire Depot and the property
behind this little sliver small piece of
land back in
1999 since that time the Troy has you
know we have maintained the piece of
property we have actually mowed it snow
removal um trash removal General Lawn
Care is needed um this includes paying
for the property to be mowed by the town
of Troy and we truly value the history
of the rail trail and since you know we
are actively working to promote it we
have a parking area where people come
they Park They Ride um we are our
Depot's open we are working with several
rail trails to put a kiosk um so that it
will show a whole map of that area um so
there's a a lot of things that we're
doing in that area to promote the rail
trail the safety we work with snow mes
we work with est state of the Hamshire
um but our Depot like I said is 176
years old fully restored one of the few
in the state and actually in the full
area to be open to the public back to
basically its original way our plan is
to restore the the budar and open that
to the public also holding events there
book signings we have a lot of local
authors that write about the rail trail
a lot of local authors that write about
the the chesher rail trail itself the
rail and the history of the of the
trains um so with the addition of 6154
we've actually now seen non-stop traffic
um to the rail trail people walking by
looking at it stopping taking a walk
that is um our rationale that we would
like to continue that in working with
the state and and with the snow mes and
everybody else to promote the rail trail
thank thank you for your comments yeah
um Mr Shay I uh if I could ask you and
um institutional memory sitting here to
my right I I don't remember coming into
many meetings and seeing a request like
this at the meeting and not hearing of
it before am I
incorrect uh no you're not incorrect
with that and I would also just like to
point out too that the charge of this
committee is to authorize the disposal
of property it's not to uh necessarily
set the cost of or the what's going to
be charged for that property um that's
really up to the governor and Council in
statute it says that property should be
disposed of at market rate which is
approved by governor and
councel thank you I I guess my question
for the department and for the the town
of Troy would you like to
postpone um this item to the next
meeting um I don't unless I hear
something differently I I don't I don't
see them going to authorize uh even
consider the offer to lower this to$ one
so okay what would the pleasure be would
you like to move it to the next and see
if you could speak to Governor counsel
or would you like us to approve or
discuss this item and approve it at the
rate that's being shown I would just say
go ahead at this point we're prepared
either way we just wanted to let you
know what we're doing with the property
that we value that
and I'm appreciative of everything
you've told us and the efforts and sure
I thank the town for that any further
questions yes Mr one thing the committee
could do is wave the um one-time
administrative fee if you chose to do
that otherwise the they'd still have to
pay the $1,100 of which apparently 500
has already been deposited with the
state
um rep M I would not be in favor of that
either I think at this point in time
I don't want to be in a position where
we're setting any kind of historical
precedent for any of this that's minute
okay thank you sandor did you want to
comment if I could Mr chairman there
there is a methodology in place where
this could be discussed by the governor
Council they can make the commitment I
think we should move it in in that in
that direction rather than doing
something here that's that's not
appropriate for this committee to do but
also recognizing the fact that Troy uh
I've only been to Troy a couple of times
but I must say I you got to come
again I was there for judge Frasier's
bachelor party and WHYY Frasier has now
been retired for a number of years can
say and Troy was a wonderful place to
visit so I think with due consideration
do has to look at this I think a
recommendation has to be made by dot to
to to GNC in order to make this happen
but the imperative is
that we're doing a lot to preserve the
historical features of of new he that
make it such a great place and the
community's involvement makes it really
worthwhile that it shows a real effort
on the part of the people to to maintain
the character of of the state and I
applaud you for that and thank you very
much for that thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you is there any further
discussion on item 038 Mr chairman okay
thank you question I noticed under
requested action it talks about the fee
uh for
$3,120 uh doar with an one-time
administrative fee of $1,100 of which
the department is in a receipt of 500 so
I'm a little confused this 3,120 it
doesn't include the rest of the
administrative fee and or how does the
500 work no the 500 is part of a
separate
$100 uh administrative fee balance
so it I'm so followup so it would be so
it would still be
3,120 yes sir all right okay good thank
you any further
discussion um on item 038 do we have a
motion motion to approve representative
Mills motion to approve seconded by
represent clud thank you um so if you're
in favor of the motion for
038 authorization sell 12,800 square
feet parcel State on chure Branch
Railroad town of Troy signified by
saying I I if you're opposed to the
motion
nay um okay one nay for yes motion
carries thank you um informational you
have in your packets
23042 Council New Hampshire Council on
resource and development and 043 New
Hampshire Council and resource
development memorandum Surplus Land
review in
Guilford is there any further discussion
on those items or
questions seeing none Mr Shay or
anything else they other than setting
the date uh that okay I suggest uh
having just come through Capital that we
had set January 26 so we 10 o'clock were
we going to go um so 10 o'clock because
we have some longer reports next week or
next month on
Capital um if there are objections to
the date schedules please let us know
but we will let that stand um any other
business before long
range seeing none motion to adjourn
represent Mills to adjourn seconded by
represent cluder thank you all those in
favor signified by saying I I I those
opposed
senator
thank you uh we
are
very